a sta ballando
rimasta mano ma senza una paurosa co2
nuovo settore hanno vedete qua è tutto
arrugginito e strano c'è qualcuno che
sta suonando il pianoforte la fatica di
super divertente ma ovviamente prima di
iniziare questo il profeta su mi piace
mettetevi comodi e annuncio importante
non c'è importante andato a vederlo in
os il link qua qua al dato vederlo dopo
questo video è
il libro storie paurose disponibile per
il pre show che fanno solo per i
primissimi che preordinano il libro
riceveranno uno mi ha detto di no to
grow foto da me firmato autografi
la di amicizie di coraggio una nuova
insegnante misteriosa creatura insomma
non voglio spoilerarvi troppo ma
preordinato stupito per risolvere la
cartolina autografata il in frame
descrizione e ora video e così quadri
nello settore e vediamo chi so proprio
dove siamo finiti
ma l'ascensore si è già sono caduto dall
ascensore
capito come la ii b fa al 20 siamo nella
scuola di baldi perché tutto così
luminoso
e baldi la scarsità di body e benji e
punjab inquinata se c'è qui
aiuto dov'è stato di
afa ballando
si no aspettano bloccata
e mezzo abbiamo appreso che ha preso mi
ha preso anche alfano porta nome giusto
mentre ha una sua storia umana era così
veloce amore e basta
wow devo dire che questo nuovo ascensore
paurose bellissimo perché le location
sono molto più grande sia anche più
belle ma non cattivo quali battisti ha
beccato di sedersi a parte
qualche personaggio che vuole farti
fuori dal popolo
non metto che volevi anche arrostire
qualche marshmallow non
scrivete nei commenti se quando poi si
farà più punti neri teo vitale io oggi
sono team arancione pesca artigianale
tipica lettera mi aspetta matteo siamo
sopravvissuti siamo sopravvissuti senza
neanche vedere il cattivo
corridoio allora proviamo ad andare di
qua domani ci siamo in un hotel
abbiamo un altro ascensore mi sembra
giusto non si chiude questo ascensore
forse non è uno pulite quando si apre il
cattivo non c'è nessuno forse mai detto
che ero
[Applauso]
siamo in un hotel assieme in un hotel
anch'io mi sono messa a letto
io sono ancora vivo
dormire attori festa tormente uno dei
sei tornate lì no io mi nascondo
impossibile scaricare
mi vado a dormire quest'altra stampa
ieri quando due figli in bagno
sono sopravvissuto questa volta sono
sopravvissuto anch'io su due ma sembrava
come una mucca di ramon grassi è un
gioco di among us media è vero sì questo
è il condono supera frollo rete un bel
team ma non posso entrare
e allora chi sarà il parente attivo sala
sarà qualcuno di among us che ci vuole
affettare quel coltello bastare il
pastore che cos'è questa lettera
forse è meglio che è vero cook qui c'è
la tanica di benzina per i reattori ma
dov'è il cattivo per ora vede anche cosa
che mi piace lasciato bel mi piace è qua
sotto perché qua ci stimola del wifi
questa è la stanza delle elettriche
allora molti molti venivano eliminati in
quella stanza perché vogliamo la luce
ricordate che ti i nostri gameplay di
amgas diversi ma perché ci sono tutti
questi crew matey quattro
o forse si sono trasformati nella
navicella dove siamo qui sembra fast
food
panini
e basta che si faccia un panino il posto
preferito di evitare allora io sto far
mangiare un ristorante ci sono pure le
patatine fritte per te vitalizi già
messa si dica che cosa vuole anche
questa campagna tso il quadro anni che
vado a mangiare ma fatta io mi nascondo
qua nel bagno spero che non entri nel
bagno delle belle come un bagno ci sono
tutti i panini le patate qualcuno faccia
il pagliaccio
ma il comune se ne accorgono
stavo baciando
fino nell'otello mi fa dormire a causa
dei cattivi difficili
nascondiamoci in una di queste stanze
anche per me stesso
io sono seduto
allora porta
insomma ora non può fare subito i
bisogni
resta bisogno in quel po di musica
mentre seduto ma io no c'è questo
coltello stava staccando non è giusto no
no no no non sono stato eliminato e lì
però però non è giusto mentre una su
facendo le sue cose non puoi arrivare
così ad aspettarlo
sono commenti in una foresta per questa
volta 107 tende abbiamo se ci sono
mangiare semina qua sono entrato qui ci
sono due le lettere cattivo fa forse un
orso morso ma che creature strana fu
lupo mannaro 1 con la testata di zucca
si aprono non lo so ma mi ha affettato
mi sta aspettando
vitale è stato eliminato e un muro con
la testa suzuka ero e rimango qua
nascosta forse ceco lan service e delle
zucche cam si è lui è lui il primo che
non mi vedano sono ritornati
vediamo quanti punti stiamo 36 48
superando vitale g
allora siamo già attenta dove credi
nascondiamo siamo lì magari vi dovete
tunisi risposta ai sì io ho detto che
qui si è messo un computer fantastico
ma cosa magrini a campione mai anche lei
non sono nè grenier computer guarda i
nostri video che l'ascom hanzala
aggravando ancora di più ce l'abbiamo
fatta siamo sopravvissuti senza neanche
a vedere il derby
siamo tornati in a boldi l'ha avuta già
eliminato quindi questa volta
nascondiamoci meglio abbiamo che abbiamo
scritto felice matematica
la mia materia preferita drucker sarà
quella che abbiamo di più
vi do uno spoiler sul libro storie
paurose perché il libro le storie
iniziano proprio a scuola perché i
protagonisti sono quattro alunni della
scuola 4 misero all'improvviso arriva un
insegnante molto misteriosa che gli
assegna una ricerca in cui dovranno
cercare delle creature ma succederanno
delle cose vi ha sbagliato troppo e ora
caduto dall assessore tu sei perché voi
in quella nella foresta c'è scritto è
sparito questo bambino di 10 anni è il
cattivo allora no è nuovamente jack
o'lantern va bene in sottofondo ma e
gigante io sono da un'altra parte invece
luogo di grande
meno male che queste mappe in questo
nuovo sensore sono grandissime e quindi
sì basta andare in giro il nasconderci
quella dietro gli alberi non mi troverà
mai
però più punti è viva ecco di timido 6
lisa
ciao ciao non ti vedo balla sopra vedo
una casetta volata sono dietro di te
eccoti finalmente ce l'abbiamo fatta ci
siamo è un parco giochi e il parco
giochi ma cosa succede se saliamo qua
sopra wow
anch'io voglio qui c'è tutto c'è anche
la nave dei pirati e privati dai temi o
schiacciando qui su questo corso che uso
ma chi è cattivo qua non c'è nessun
cattivo e non lo so sto salendo sulle
montagne russe a piedi è stato
veloce cattivo
cattivo che bello io voglio esplorare
tutto con tre sport bellissimo che
scrivo qua non so come riusciamo a
respirare chi è
huawei sta esplorando tutto qui invece
rientrare subito di 20 partite
che con seguito dell'assunzione
no no no io invece sto esplorando
dappertutto che hanno raccattato è
ancora dentro all'assessore laggiù c'è
anche patrick si cambia vediamo
solo cattivo come si chiama posso andare
si chiami jeff the killer possono
rimanere in pace in bagno a fare i miei
sentimenti
foto 1 ma leggete qui il passo il bagno
anche tu dovevi andare in bagno e
arrivato gia
no no no mi stanno facendo affetto
mentre stavo veramente nell'istituto
è eterno nell'ascensore non m'interessa
aspettato qualcuno
come quasi tutti sono stati eliminati
sono fermi razzola siamo
che preso po strana chi è secondo voi il
cattivo qua
non riesco a capire chi potrebbe essere
un castello forse c'è un drago
bellissima questa mappatura ottico una
sorta di un castello per dario che bella
e abbiamo già fatto andare così bello
ogni tanto si impositivo ce le possiamo
esplorare ma pesante capezzali una
pizzeria
e poi ci sono i personaggi di file
nights freddi io meno una pizzeria
cercando di prendere la pizza cui si
faccia una pizza per la gioia di vitale
questa è la festa di compleanno ho
capito troppo che usciranno i personaggi
di file noi se io mi nascondo questo
prodotto
finale
dove la prima nave lavaggio io no no no
non te la dico è tutto per me
all'entrata e uscita è uscito nei freddi
cosa riuscito freddo la pizza freddino
l'olio tanto
la pizza lamentata calda mica freddi
anch'io chiuchiolo d'arda punti contro
68 punti non è possibile cominciare da
come si fanno a fare più punti
bene vi sopravvivere per più tempo e
devi anche esplorare di più la mappa
bello siamo ancora vivo ma allora
andiamo avanti
che succede miss è incastrata una gand
dal medico bottino
vitale è stato eliminato perché proviamo
scappare adesso dobbiamo nell'ascensore
dall'altra parte la scienza ora mi si è
passato davanti aiuto aiuto aiuto ma
sbaglio questo cattivo mette anche della
musica stata wow mistero però strappare
di nuovo team e roma le contributi 6 io
non c'è più il mio volto appunti e tu 72
è un personaggio con noi che ha fatto
132 punti siamo l'uva 20 o bikini bottom
foro provò andare in quella sfera lì in
cui viveva quel per spagnolo diamo
dattolo che cosa sia arrivato il
terremoto io provo entrare qua chiuso a
caldo sopra così magari non riesce a
prendermi
vedere tutta la mappa solo da krusty
krab invece non riuscirai mai a
prendervi d'acqua spa
scommetto dovrei mangiare un panino
certo solo sulla casa pedica l'asti
grubbs al ristorante dei grassi grado
medie di no tu dove sei non ti credono
io sono sopra la sfera o no
abbiamo fatta per un pelo perché stava
stata proprio soprattutto
questo è posto a kiwan kiwan kiwan lo
vedi qua dove dove costruiamo il pupazzo
prima di entrare ma il problema è vero
la pappa id a chi guardi ma c'è ma
perché
di uova con lo zucchero in testa vedi
che il corpo e fino agli
ultimi due livelli vediamo se vitale
riuscirà a recupero sopravviva rosino
tutto la vediamo colorare il cut lago
comunque benissimo questo castello
tourist loro
c'è un ponte in legno dove porterà con
sé per potervi apre la porta e allora no
qua dentro cos'è questo
non ho fatto in tempo ad esplorare
ancora siamo di nuovo dai linguaggi
prossimo livello
vediamo se questa voce c'è ancora a chi
guardi con la testa da zucca non so
perché eccolo per come qui ma vediamo
preparato cavasin
forse bisogna stati l'asso o no
da dodici a prendervi anche da qua io
sono quel dietro non mi prende e poi
passare
siamo tornati da grillo e irene come
ultimo livello e bellissimo questo anche
perché voglio vedere gremi dove serve
nulla i primi grandi re mida
nascosta
credi
sia separata soggiorno e fragile non c'è
sento la
fame dei gremi pocho c'è un augurio a
quando il grado la posso mangiare
ho sentito mai però qualcuno è stato
preso dal
grandissimo livello e
ecco cos'era lo so che l'altro doveva
essere l'ultimo livello ma è proprio
vero che totò come ero curiosa di vedere
che cosa usciva è questa l'anima era
stato eliminato ma chi è cattivo qua c'è
solo una casetta
c'è qualcuno qui guarda mi
auguro vivamente jack o'lantern
che succede
se si sparita sono tornata alla 9 io ho
fatto 120 punti evitare affatto 108 di
nuto
nominato o lasciate un bel mi piace mi
ricordo di preordinare storie paurose
cliccato nel link descrizione scomoda
come pre ordine con la mia cartolina
autografata solo per i primi che
prenderanno il libro e ora vi lasciamo
con quattro casalinghe su cui cliccare
per vedere inoltre altri video cliccate
su quella che preferite buona visione
ciao